You didn't start my timer.
President Obama: We're in the middle of the
longest streak of private sector job creation
in history.
More than 14 million new jobs, the strongest
2 years of job growth since the 1990s, an
unemployment rate cut in half.
Michael: In his final State of the Union address,
President Obama touted the fact that the unemployment
rate has been cut in half.
The President is right to celebrate the unemployment
rate.
Its fall represents the alleviation of hardship
for millions of American workers.
Unfortunately the job market has much further
to go before all Americans who can be working
and who should be working are in jobs that
they're satisfied with.
And unfortunately, several of the policies
the President has championed throughout the
course of his administration have made it
harder to find a job, not easier.
Let's take two.
One is the minimum wage.
The President is wrong to insist on a higher
minimum wage.
Raising the minimum wage makes it harder for
people to work.
Instead, the President should be touting wage
subsidies that pull people into the work force
and that encourage work.
In addition, the Affordable Care Act should
be repealed and replaced in a responsible
manner that makes it possible for Americans
who want health insurance to get it, but that
doesn't erect barriers to employment.
So what do you think of President Obama's
legacy?
Let us know if there are any other topics
you would like to see AEI scholars discuss
in 60 seconds.
And be sure to check out other State of the
Union responses from my AEI colleagues.